[Music]
something new from the world of giant
robots Transformers 1 a fully animated
film is coming to theaters and tells the
prequel story of Optimus Prime and
Megatron on their home planet Cybertron
learn everything that is currently known
about the new Transformers movie in this
video
recently Paramount Pictures tried to
Breathe new life into the franchise with
Transformers rise of the beasts the
movie was supposed to be the Prelude to
a new trilogy but sadly without much
success with worldwide box office
takings of 438 million dollars it failed
to reach the level of its predecessors
and is thus probably considered a
disappointment so now all hope is put in
the animated spin-off Transformers 1
which can likely be produced at a much
lower cost than a live action movie real
locations or actors are not required
here anyway as the prequel is set
entirely on the Transformers home planet
Transformers 1 will return to the roots
of the franchise and deal with the Epic
civil war between the autobots and the
Decepticons on Cybertron the film is
expected to tell the story of how
Optimus Prime and Megatron went from
former friends to Bitter enemies Lorenzo
di bonaventura longtime producer of the
series already announced that we will
see Cybertron in a way that we had never
experienced before also featured our
Sentinel Prime and Alpha Trion one of
the oldest Autobots ever they are
expected to play a major role in the
story a few years ago Netflix already
released an animated series called
Transformers Warfare Cybertron which
also dealt with the Great War
Transformers 1 comes with a Top Class
cast which has already caused quite a
stir Thor star Chris Hemsworth will
embody Optimus Prime in a dubbing role
of course and Hemsworth is not the only
Marvel veteran involved in the project
for instance it was announced that
Scarlett Johansson will dub the role of
Elita a member of the Autobots the role
of fan favorite bumblebee will be played
by Keegan Michael Key and Jon Hamm will
provide the voice of Sentinel Prime
Optimus Prime's Mentor Lawrence
Fishburne for his part provides the
voice for Alpha Trion the Decepticons
are led by Brian Tyree Henry who will
dub the super villain Megatron the star
cast already shows that this is not a
cheap production the legendary director
Steven Spielberg will once again be the
producer as well as Michael Bay who
already directed the first five films
the screenplay is by Andrew Barr and
Gabriel Ferrari who previously worked as
writers for Ant-Man and the WASP Josh
Cooley will direct the film he was
already able to win over the audience
with Toy Story 4 and should be the
perfect director for this animated
action spectacle needless to say there
is a lot of excitement about what style
Transformers were will have in the end
so far there are no clues about the
film's look apart from artwork and
lettering as with the previous movies
though the computer animations are by
industry expert industrial Light and
Magic
Transformers 1 is currently still in
production and this has been temporarily
suspended due to the current actors and
writer strike if the strike continues
for a longer period of time the planned
theatrical release on September 13th
2024 may not be feasible of course we
hope the production will resume soon
after all we are eagerly awaiting the
first images or even a teaser trailer
that reveals more about the project The
Producers already have big plans Lorenzo
de bonaventura talked back in April
about wanting to tell the prequel story
of the Transformers in form of a Trilogy
so should Transformers 1 prove to be
successful we might be in for a
Transformers 2 or a Transformers 3 as
well one thing seems certain anyway fans
can look forward to more movies for
years to come what do you think are you
confident that the prequel will perform
well are you fans of the Transformers
and if so which one is your favorite
movie please let us know in the comments
[Music]
thank you